GRASS.
>> Tucker: SO IS PELOSI THE
SECRET GRAND WIZARD?
WE'LL SEE IF SHE GETS DENOUNCED,
TOO.
CAN'T WAIT.
READY TO GET A GUN CONTROL
LECTURE NEXT TIME YOU GO TO
DOCTOR.
DOCTORS ARE BEING URGED TO
CAMPAIGN FOR GUN CONTROL AND HOW
UNSAFE IT IS TO OWN GUNS.
THE EDITORIAL SAYS DON'T LET
YOUR CONCERNS FOR PERCEIVED
POLITICAL VIEWS.
DOCTOR, THANKS FOR COMING IN.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I WAS READING ABOUT
THIS AND YOU SAID THAT THE
MASSACRE IN LAS VEGAS URGED YOU
TO DO THIS.
WOULD THIS HAVE PRESENTED THAT?
THAT IF YOU TOLD THIS TO STEPHEN
PADDOCK THAT HE WOULDN'T HAVE
OPENED FIRE?
>> NO.
THAT'S NOT WHAT OUR PROPOSAL IS.
WE TREAT FIREARM INJURY LIKE A
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM THAT IT'S
BECOME.
ONE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT IS
FOR DOCTOR TO TALK TO PATIENTS
THAT ARE AT RISK FOR INJURING
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS WITH GUNS
AND HOW TO DEAL WITH IT MORE
SAFELY.
>> Tucker: SO YOU'RE NOT AN
EXPERT ON GUNS.
WOULD IT BE UNCOMFORTABLE IF I
GAVE YOU MEDICAL ADVICE?
>> YEAH, THAT WOULD.
>> Tucker: ME TOO.
THAT'S WHY I WOULDN'T DO IT.
>> I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON GUNS.
I AM A MEDICAL EXPERT.
PART OF WHAT PHYSICIANS DO IS TO
ASSESS RISK AND HELP TALK TO
THEIR PATIENTS ABOUT MITIGATING
THOSE RISKS.
>> Tucker: ASSESS RISK.
LIKE WHEN YOU SEND TENS OF
MILLIONS OF OPIOIDS NO TO
APPALACHIA.
HOW ABOUT THAT RISK?
>> WE DO ASSESS RISK.
IT WASN'T DOCTORS THAT SEND TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOSES OF OPIOIDS
TO APPALACHIA OR OTHER PLAYS.
>> Tucker: YES, IT WAS.
>> WE ASSESS HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE, SMOKING, RISKY SEXUAL
BEHAVIOR THAT PEOPLE PUTS AT
RISK FOR INFECTIONS.
LIKE WHEN PEOPLE ARE ELDERLY AND
AT RISK FOR FALLS.
WE ASK ABOUT AREA RUGS IN THE
HOME.
WE TALK TO PATIENTS ABOUT --
LOTS OF DIFFERENT RISKS THAT WE
ASSESS.
THIS PROPOSAL IS TO REMIND
PHYSICIANS THAT WHEN THEY HAVE A
PATIENT THAT IS AT RISK FOR
HARMING THEMSELVES OR OTHERS TO
ASK ABOUT WHETHER THEY HAVE GUNS
IN THE HOME AND TALK TO THEM
ABOUT MORE SAFELY STORING THOSE
GUNS OR OTHER INTERVENTIONS THAT
CAN MAKE THEM AND THEIR FAMILY
SAFER.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT
SHOULD HAVE A GUN IN A HOME?
IF THERE'S A TOUGH AREA WHERE
THERE'S HOME INVASIONS, WOULD
YOU'D SAY YOU BETTER HAVE A WAY
TO DEFEND YOURSELF?
>> AS A PHYSICIAN I WOULD NOT.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE
ANY MY PURVIEW TO DO.
IT'S CERTAINLY PEOPLE'S RIGHT IN
THIS COUNTRY.
IF THAT PERSON WAS AT RISK OF
HARMING THEMSELVES OR OTHERS,
I'D COUNSEL THEM MAYBE THEY
SHOULDN'T.
>> Tucker: IF THE POINT OF THIS
IS HARM REDUCTION AS YOU CLAIM
IT WAS, THEN IF SOMEONE WAS A
DELIVERY MAN IN A TOUGH
NEIGHBORHOOD DELIVERING THE
NEWSPAPER OR DELIVERING TO
BODEGAS AT 3:00 A.M., WOULDN'T
YOU SAY IT'S BETTER TO BE ARMED?
>> ACTUALLY, TUCKER THERE ARE
DATA OUT THERE THAT SHOW THAT IF
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO A GUN IN
THEIR HOME, IT DOESN'T KEEP THEM
SAFER.
THEY'RE HIGHER RISK FOR
COMPLETED SUICIDE OR A GUN
HOMICIDE.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE GUNS IN THEIR
HOME.
SO YOUR ASSUMPTION THAT HAVING A
GUN IN YOUR HOPE KEEPS YOUR
SAFER, THERE'S DAY THAT THAT
REFUTES THAT ASSUMPTION.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK YOU
KNOW THE DATA.
WHEN YOU TAKE SUICIDE OUT OF
THAT, IT'S A DIFFERENT PICTURE.
THAT'S A SEPARATE QUESTION TO
ASK YOU ABOUT.
WHETHER YOU'RE AGAINST SUICIDE
AND TRYING TO PREVENT SUICIDE.
IS THERE NO CIRCUMSTANCE SAFER
WITH A GUN?
>> NO.
IN THE SYSTEMATIC REVIEW PUN
ESTABLISHED IN THE ANNALS OF
INTERNAL MEDICINE, SUICIDE AND
WHETHER THE PERSON HAD GUNS IN
THE HOME, THE RISK FOR A
COMPLETED SUICIDE AND THE GUN
HOMICIDE WAS HIGHER FOR
INDIVIDUALS --
>> I'M FAMILIAR WITH THOSE
STATISTICS.
THEY'RE MISLEADING.
I'M SURPRISED YOU'RE CITING
THEM.
SERIOUS PEOPLE KNOW THAT.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
I'M DISABLED AND I LIVE AT THE
END OF A LONG ROAD WHERE THE
POLICE CAN'T GET THERE WITHIN
TEN MINUTES, THERE'S HOME
INVASIONS, I FEEL I NEED A GUN,
WOULD YOU SAY NO, YOU DON'T NEED
A GUN?
WHAT WOULD BE YOUR ADVICE?
>> THAT'S THE PATIENT'S CHOICE.
BUT IF THE PATIENT WAS DEPRESSED
AND AT RISK FOR SUICIDE OR
HAVING HOMICIDAL IDEATIONS OR
COGNITIVE DEFICITS, I WOULD
PROBABLY COUNSEL THEM THAT IT
WAS MORE SAFE FOR THEM NOT TO
HAVE A GUN THAN HAVE A GUN.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FAIR.
IF THE PERSON WAS GOING TO KILL
THEMSELVES, YOU'RE RIGHT.
SO YOU AS AN ORGANIZATION HAVE
TAKEN A STRONG POSITION AGAINST
SUICIDE, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: NOT ALL PHYSICIANS
HAVE.
>> MANY PHYSICIANS ARE -- I
DON'T THINK THERE'S MANY
PHYSICIANS THAT ADVOCATE
SUICIDE, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
LIKE THE ENTIRE STATE OF OREGON
WHERE IT'S LEGAL AND A LOT OF
PHYSICIANS PARTICIPATE IN IT.
THERE'S A LOT THAT ARE FOR
SUICIDE.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT ISSUE.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ASSISTANT
SUICIDE FOR THOSE AT THE END OF
THEIR LIFE.
THAT HAS NO IDEA --
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
PEOPLE SHOOT THEMSELVES WITH
GUNS ALL THE TIME IN TERMINAL
PAIN OR FACING A TERMINAL
ILLNESS.
YOU'RE SAYING SUICIDE IS OKAY
WITH A PHYSICIAN -- I'M TRYING
TO GET TO THE NUT OF WHAT YOU
BELIEVE.
>> I THINK SUICIDE WITH A GUN IS
MESSY AND NOT SOMETHING THAT
PHYSICIANS SUPPORT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
LOST --
>> Tucker: BUT SUICIDE WITH A
NEEDLE IS OKAY.
>> WHAT?
>> Tucker: SUICIDE WITH A NEEDLE
IS OKAY BUT SUICIDE WITH A GUN
IS WRONG BECAUSE IT'S MESSY?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
>> IT'S WRONG.
PHYSICIAN ASSISTED SUICIDE IS
NOT DONE WITH INJECTION DRUGS.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT EUTHANASIA
WHICH IS NOT LEGAL IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> YOU'RE DEAD AT THE END NO
MATTER WHAT.
DOESN'T SEEM A DIFFERENT
CATEGORY TO ME.
OBVIOUSLY YOU DISAGREE.
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT WE WERE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE FIRE AIR
INJURY?
>> Tucker: WE WERE BUT THE
MAJORITY ARE SUICIDES AS YOU
SAID.
SO YOU'RE TRYING TO PROTECT THEM
FROM THAT, AS YOU SAID, SO I WAS
TRYING TO GET TO THE NUB OF WHAT
YOU BELIEVE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S AN OPTION TO
SPEW PLATITUDES.
SO --
>> IF YOU GIVE ME AN
OPPORTUNITY, I WILL.
SO WHAT --
>> Tucker: I THINK I HAVE.
DOCTOR, I THINK I'VE GIVEN YOU